Oh God Oh now come back please art now
so as you probably noticed I am doing
something slightly different today well
I'm not doing something slightly
different Kier and is doing something
different he's taken control of my
camera and is decided that the best
thing to do of it is to put it on a jib
and then sort of move it around my face
for a while my hope is that this will be
the coolest looking video blog in the
world ever but my worry is probably that
it's gonna be quite disconcerting more
than anything else please no stop I
guess when it comes to this there are
two things I need to explain to you a
what a jib is and B what a Kiran is this
is what a jib looks like it's basically
a mini crane thingy with a big arm
coming off a tripod it looks cool and it
makes things look cool as well and this
is what a Kiran looks like and yes he
does look like this pretty much all the
time though whereas my head gone now
okay I feel kind of weird about the fact
that I haven't introduced you to Kiran
yet because he has been living in my
house for about a month you might
remember a while ago in my microbe 3
video when I mentioned the fact that my
friend Michael is meant to be moving
into this house pretty soon but
unfortunately due to visas being
horrible things and stuff he's not here
yet still and so in the meantime we have
Kiran if you see my Forever Yours music
video then you're actually already aware
of Karin's work because he filmed that
whole video with his magical camera
hands he's essentially like a one-man
film crew and with that he just has a
hell of a lot of video equipment
including this strange contraption which
he's been pestering me to use in a vlog
for ages so if you're feeling seasick at
all because of all of these weird camera
moves you can't blame me it's all
Karen's fault he made me do it is the
mic and shot that mostly okay
hello mister microphone just a bit of
housekeeping before I go I have some
good news and I have some bad news the
bad news is that unfortunately I'm not
going to be able to make a
midlife-crisis week video tomorrow but
the good news is that the reason I'm not
gonna be able to make a video tomorrow
is because I'm going to be spending the
entire day on various planes going to
America I'm still gonna be making just
as many videos as I said I would but the
last two are gonna be on Tuesday and
Wednesday instead when I will be staying
with the great Hank green so I hope
that's okay so that's it for blog with a
jib I hope this video has been at least
vaguely watchable I'm gonna go impact
now okay bye you've just had the almost
imponderable joy of watching Charlie is
so cool like which makes you like cool
if you've seen the Forever Yours music
video that I'm
then you're actually already aware of
seven Kieran's work seven Kieran's work
seven Kieran's were someone else oh
there's okay you are having fun Anya